millions of young faithful thronged
copacabana beach for an
open-air mass that resembled a gigantic
party the crowds grew
every day during pope francis's visit to
brazil for world youth day
this was the final chance to see the
pontiff before his return to the vatican
in his homily francis called on young
catholics to spread the message of the
gospel around the world
the pope said it was good to be here for
world youth day
and to share our faith together with
young people
now it's your turn to pass this
experience on to others
jesus calls on you to be disciples on a
mission
brazilian president dima rousseff and
other south american heads of state
attended the mass
silence for more than a minute after the
sermon as the crowd reflected on what
they'd heard
the pope's mission was to spark new
interest in catholicism
among young people and present a more
down-to-earth church
judging by the interests he seems to
have succeeded
a message francis plans to maintain
through the next world youth day
slated for poland in 2016.